in the shade at the channels at m youtube
interview with jean claude juncker hugh
jones very happy to be among you
with the president of the
european commission jean claude juncker who are
joining us the studio very happy to
see you again
we were singing s12 you presented your
statement on the state of the union
it was going to talk about subjects like
investments security defense
among others of course how do
you think it was docked I do
n't know but it was not my main
concern I said  what I had to
say by sending this message and
we have to keep our
commitments anyway we have to take
concrete measures and I have the impression
that the majority of members of parliament
support us and we have the
European press who have  well received the message
as the parliament of the french challenge
and we have a new challenge for
today with three youtube creators
waiting here in the wings who
are impatient  ents who have a lot of
questions to ask you
they are valuable to us who
asked them questions to
send you the last time the last
opportunity was with president
barack obama who did not
know the questions in advance either  so there
will definitely be a few surprises i
don't like the interviews prepared is
wonderful because yonath our first
creator he is 19 years old he has over a
million followers on youtube the same
as a book about his experience he
just  germany so
please follow me please find younes
hello yonath treasure will have to
meet
i'm happy to meet you
too now i can open my
jacket
here please
because it's very hot in brussels
the people have to  people know a
survey on board my name is younès and
today I have an
extraordinary opportunity to meet the
president of the european
commission asked a certain number  of questions
that are of course of interest to all my
followers
when she the last chemistry video
the opportunity to ask a number of
questions on European politics and
its various questions I wanted them to be
passed on to the whole
community
first of all thank you d  give up this
opportunity thank you fishermen it's about
politics I deal with a lot of
social media
first question politics is
not business is indeed but it's
your activity
oh yes I deal with politics that
do you think of social networks
I'm not really a fowler of
social media
I don't have time for that it must
be said but from time to time I
take a look at
it there are a lot of things that I like
we read we read some  things that please
and then there are things
these nonsense sometimes that one finds there
please me a little less because
it is not in conformity with reality
bordeaux it is true it is true that are
in advertising  huge lic on three young audiences
my first question I won't ask you
in a few moments before the
Polish and French colleagues
so why do you think this is
the right time to reach so many
young people through this interview I admit that
I have  always seen this necessity
the fact of doing it now it was
your idea it was not mine but
I really like your idea the idea of
meeting you and
meeting other young people not only young people
from elsewhere but  to meet
people directly it's a
unique opportunity to be able to do that they actually got
up it's a good thing
that it allowed it touches a lot
of people and I hope that a lot
of questions about my review  so my
next question the european union eu
is a fairly complex concept for me
of course i gained a lot of
knowledge at school in politics in
law and i was able to learn moreover that
they were 28 states  m  bers
yes sometimes we fall asleep it's true
we suspected it it's true it happened to me
too but I think I reflect the
number of young people my age who
wonder who wonder what they do in
concrete terms  the european union so
can you give us three reasons
why we young people
need europe
the first reason for the youngest
and perhaps more difficult to conceive
it is about peace in europe
my father who is dead  in August
had been forced to be a soldier
during the second world war
so the non existence of europe he
he lived in his own flesh my own
generation already grew up in peace even
if we went through crises but
n  let's not forget that this is
something unheard of we have 40 wars in the
world but none in europe
apart from perhaps what we saw in
ukraine
it is therefore about peace this is the
first reason and  then it's
secondly about the future because we
have c  he dilemma peace war which
perhaps does not speak directly to young people
, perhaps wrongly, but I was saying that
it is about the future
at the beginning of the 20th century
it was the night before last 20% of
Europeans represented the
world population now it's 7% and we
will go down to 4% very soon 4%
of ten billion people
so since we are already the
smallest continent we are less and
less numerous and our weight in this
world economy  and also decreases
for this international economy we
see the numbers increasing and
we are less and less
present so the answer could
be that the national
states are facing the rest of the world and
can face the rest of the world in
isolation from each other  others it's crazy
we have to come together we
have the chinese we have the other
continents so we have to look
outwards to keep our
influence at the rhdp level a  of course,
but at the international level
this directly concerns the channels
because it is these young people who are
growing up in today's world
there will soon be fewer Europeans and
I may not see it
when  there will be even
fewer Europeans but what that means
is that we have an
international scale and we have to exist on
an international scale you
asked for three reasons if I remember
correctly so
I come to the third reason
there are few people who
may share this opinion but europe
is not just a stain on our
continent peace work employment
no we have a role which the
whole world and europe will not have  not finished here
this work this task I believe that there
are thousands of children who die
every day in the world because they
do not have enough to eat so we have
a task to take on at the planetary level
otherwise we  are going to face the
vengeance of  those who today
may not have enough to eat what i
have again a question that you have been
asked often in many
member states there is the question of whether
same-sex couples can
marry having  children and well the
european union said that it was a matter of
national competence
so why are there areas in
which the union intervenes and others
where the member states are competent the
treaties simply say so
there are certain areas  which fall within the
competence of the member states
personally i think that we must be
able to approach things
2 in
a clear and clean way and calmly
so here we
considered equalization when i was in
luxembourg i was responsible for
in luxembourg and it  there must be no
sexual discrimination on the
basis of the sexual orientation of each
person homosexuals
lesbians are people who love each other so
why is  what a state should
prohibit this love between two people
is something that I have never
understood I think that we should
respect all people and we
should not think here that we can
do politics  if you don't
like people you have to like people and
you liked people very much it really happens to be
a remarkable approach
my next question concerns a
much more serious issue
terrorism you spoke about it in our
speech yesterday so unfortunately
europe is also affected, especially
in france, we have had
really shocking images and obviously that
all the young people too
he is a young man
wonders whether as a european citizen
should be afraid in the future of being affected
by  an attack
what the european union can do
since 2004 there were 30 attacks in
europe last year 14 and the most
serious in france and
brussels hundreds of people died
innocently
there are many innocent people who lose
their lives elsewhere in the world but
these people are not dead and that is
why in the countries of
the European Union we have
an obligation to exchange information
we must protect  our
external borders and we are in the
process of doing it it will be operational at
the end of the year we are very close
to adopting this piece of legislation we
must know who is arriving in europe and
who is leaving europe
we must  know more and
don't say it because there I'm
allergic I don't want to say that it's
a state that will have to interfere in
the smallest corners of the private lives of
its citizens no it's not a question for
the  the state of interfering in the intimacy
in the private life of citizens
because indeed in europe
there is a rule which is worth it is the
respect of the private life but it is nevertheless necessary to
know who is held in europe
who arrives in europe who travels on
the territory  European territory
and it is not out of misplaced curiosity
on the part of a state to take an
interest in it,
so your second question concerned
the fear of Europeans, you should know that
if we have to reduce the fear of
citizens, we must act
the former politician another subject the
policy of refugees and migrants
a very controversial subject in germany and
elsewhere in the european union
you also spoke about it in your
speech you said that we had
to show more solidarity must
come from the  bottom of my heart in the
comments of many people
are very positive and wish to provide
active help
many are those who wonder
how we can help migrants on
an individual level and there are
hundreds of thousands of people in
luxembourg and elsewhere that I know and
who have made it a very personal affair
so I am thinking of people aged 15 to 22
for example and who have welcomed
refugees into their homes,
that is something  which does not always go without
saying even if it
sometimes seems normal and so far I
would like in the future it is that
young people are enormously committed in this
field few people know it
but europe is a has been a country
immigration migrations
you have mcdonald's in the united states
that came from england or ireland
we spread all over
our planet we were accepted
as europeans we were very
happy about it at the time and we have  been able to
participate in the creation of certain
states so I do not forget that but we
must not forget the reason for this
flight of this wave of refugees and in
the social networks it must be said that we
see moreover that there are sometimes
speeches that are held on the
refugees as if they were all
terrorists
we cannot avoid that there are
terrorists among the refugees
it is true but I expect from young people a
warm welcome a warm solidarity
and I think that  'he  you have to
fight the extremists anyway,
but this fight has rather
pushed europe back
I'm not talking about a military fight
of course if you want to confront
populist speeches or extremist speeches
you can't just settle
for  always repeating the same thing
you have to say concretely what it
is to say and if you were in this
situation if your children had nothing
to eat
if you saw bombardments above
the heads of your children what are
you  would you stand with your arms folded
and wait for a grenade to explode in
front of you no you wouldn't
just sit there doing nothing I think you
would take children under your arm and you would
decide to leave and that's the reason
why  many people or
else in europe we don't always see it
and it's due to the fact
that europe is a kind of refuge for
many countries in the world
that's why young people
have the duty have the task
here  you  like older people
to commit to respect for
human rights for this protection
that we find in europe those who are
prosecuted what women are
raped about which children suffer and
are tortured to death these people  there will
always have their place in europe with a
turn i am still we are all getting old
it is not a secret it will happen
it will also happen fragueules d'ishtar
a question how do you see the union
in 50 years what is your vision
movies everything  maybe but how
do you see it inundating 50 years i know
what it shouldn't look like in any way
i don't believe in this concept
seduced here war at the turn of the
century
i know what i don't want is this  what
I would like is and it is not at
all my conception what I do
not wish is that we are the united states
of america
it is different we will live from our
diversity we have a more
complex landscape we  have here
nat cultures  regional groups of
different sensitivities and we must not
make Europe a melting pot a magma I have
already said this in parliament and those
who would say the opposite ignore the
sensitivities of the populations people
do not wish you have the Bavarians the
Luxembourgers  the Walloons and the
Flemings who wish to keep and
remain what they are, but what
is needed is to have a
firmer, wider sphere of solidarity, we
must indeed together agree to
live together precisely
and we must see what  what is necessary
to do in europe, i.e. we
must be more concrete europe must
be more understandable in brussels in
strasbourg which really understands
europe these two cities therefore europe
which is sometimes far away must be explained
we need more
europe a better europe
it makes no sense in terms of defence,
for example to have a country that
would assume the whole of the defense
of europe
the cam  American loincloth does not give us any
clues the Americans are no
longer ready to assume their
military interventions in Europe
believe me I am not in favor of
the militarization of Europe far from it
but I still think that it is  of
our responsibility to guarantee order
and security on our continent
this is what we will need in
the future to have a better europe
for digital
well we are currently in the process
of launching this process
it will be a process  long enough that
will last until 2025
we need wifi everywhere
connectivity we need it
everywhere in europe no one should be
excluded from this development
we must at national and
European level
fight against youth unemployment  which
is too high
cost too high we must
redouble our efforts we do not want to become the
continent of youth unemployment
your generation and even those who
come behind you v  You are young
it's true but there are others who
are even younger than you our
commitment to your
generation is not to tell you that you
will be worse off than your parents so
otherwise we would have lost  or like this
cat last question you are the
president of the european commission
you have a lot of experience but
you have like everyone else already made
some mistakes in any case your
generation to point out three things to them
three messages to communicate to us
the young  generation what we can
do better than your generation what
would it be more about i'm not
really representative of my generation
or the generation before
you who are in the labor
force but my mistakes i will come back to
this  that you mentioned previously
the fact of not loving others it
would be a mistake
it is valid for everyone and I hold to
this idea which is perhaps naive it is
true but I believe that  all men
have the same value must have the
same rights and we must not deprive
anyone of their future
we should be more
interested in people who live on another
continent africa is a continent and
is in full evolution  is a
continent for which we should
not show charity we should
invest in africa this is what we
are already doing but it is not enough
even if it is important when it comes
to refugees from famine poverty in
the world we must not just
cry
we must act concretely this is the
reason why European governments
industry
associations companies must absolutely
invest in africa this is what will
determine the future inclusion that it is
indeed  very important thank you very
much mr juncker for
answering all his questions
im sure many of the
questions from our community
you are answered thank you very much for taking
the t  time to answer us it was a
great pleasure for me too ok guen
sir length thank you for joining me
that is to say that you really had
a very nice hinder the ale exchange
which is what you were able to cover a
large number  of topics you have traveled back
in time the past the present
the future with our partner we
receive a lot of questions
thanks to the hashtag ask length nothing a
topic that yu did not sound mentioned but
that you touched on in your
famous speech excites a  question of a punk
site is a symptom and not the cause
if it didn't enter the cause things
will get worse
so what do you think is the
main reason the cause of the bric site
it's a very simple question with
thousands of replies rex
it means something is wrong
in europe but it means there
was also something wrong
in the united kingdom for 40 years if you
explain to the public that
the european union is  st stupid that
it is worth nothing that you have to leave the union
and that the european union is worth nothing
and that you are denying the advantages so it
should not surprise you that when
you ask the question of staying or
leaving
you  have a significant number of
brits who have said it is better to
leave there are so many lies
being told about europe or
half-truths circulating here and there
so it should come as no surprise at the
result but it is not  is not the only
possible explanation for the vote
I believe that there was also a message
Europeans are sulking ghana thank you
very much we will now move on to
our second creator pretty laetitia a
few months about her and well from
france and on her channel she likes to talk
subjects such as ecology recycling
she also participated in an
initiative and yuv titled yourself from the
film the objective being to fight
speech well say so
settle down thank you welcome to my
living room yes the one in  my life to young people
must know that it is an artificial living room
but you have taken an
influence on they are getting
very close and it is very well done I
wanted to thank you already 2 me for
receiving me and allowing me to meet you
I am  we really would have been delighted
because you are at the head of the
highest authority in europe and this is a
wonderful opportunity for me to be able
to ask you questions about my
community and to be able to represent the
young people of europe the young French people  so
thank you very much for welcoming me
so I had a first question a
lot of young Europeans are very
sensitive to ecology and the effects of
chemicals on our health and
on my youtube channel for example I
talk a lot about all these subjects
because  I am going to be a mother one day and
the environment in which my children will grow up
is very important. One point
that is important to me is the
question of normal endocrine disruptors.
sorry because I can't manage to be a
mother and I'm not convinced that it
's not linked, moreover, on this
famous question of endocrine
disruptors, the European commission
has only pushed back for two
and a half years the  ban and it also reminds me of
the question of the roundup which is
at the origin of many camps of
many cancers of the people who are
exposed and who could not either been who
did not read that he did not  been banned by
force I come to have the feeling
that perhaps the role of the
commission would ultimately be to
dangle us bans that do
not happen and that perhaps gives time to
multinationals to continue to earn a
lot  money and selling
chemical products that hurt us so
the question I would like to
ask you sir length is how
not to be worried and
how can you
reassure me but we are working on these
subjects  and  work in these subjects there
are in the scientific world different
appreciations on the products of which you
speak me I am rather on the side of
those finally I would not say of those who
are afraid okay but of those who
wonder and sometimes  I
wonder if the scientific opinions which
are published and which are distributed to the
whole planet are exempt from the influence
of the large producer groups and therefore the
commission is working on this subject and
we do not take it lightly, it is
okay subject  so i am how to say
impressed by the
problem okay thank you so my second
question is the following
your predecessor in the post of the
european commission mr barroso
joined goldman sachs that summer and i
was personally challenged by this
choice because i  I asked myself the
question as a citizen,
when he had his role as president, was he
not complacent, perhaps with
his future employer or is it
now  Although he holds a position in
a private bank, he did not arrive
with state secrets in his pockets,
for example, but
it is doubtful that these are not very important
because my doubts
concern many others  also
here but in any case decided they
were mine but it's not knowing the
most important thing I think
and concerning this appointment you
declared in the daily newspaper in the evening that it
was not a problem for us that he
works in  a private bank
insofar as he had respected the deadlines
of 18 months which are imposed by European law
,
so I understand that too, but
you added that the fact that they
work for this bank where you
pose a problem
and  suddenly I was surprised I was
a little bit lost because I did
n't understand very well and I was
wondering why this
bank in particular poses a problem
I don't understand very well finally
yes first of all I  believe that  e the
barroso manual dyed anti lgv honest yes no
doubt
it's a friend it rained the decision to
join the group as a sex after
a deadline that imposes talent while such a stringent
code of conduct
does not exist in any of our states  members
not even in the country you
know best and therefore France
whose rules he respected so I
don't see a big problem in the
fact that he sums up the finance sector well,
others envy him elsewhere
tablets stolen that is assigned for
example if a guy creed a big
company to become a minister
nobody asks questions as
if the one who was in the solidly
paid service of a big firm a big
company of a big bank
would not carry  in his new function
all the knowledge and all the reflexes
that we have been able to acquire
by working in the private sector there
we ask ourselves the medication but if a
politician leaves the
political scene to join the
private sphere  and which is only normal
in the United States where there is a mix
between public post and private post
everyone is asking questions
what did I say I said I
repeat myself  a problem that take job
a function in a private bank of
pass to the pass that gold a sex was
one of those sets that contributed
know not knowing to the emergence
of a huge economic financial
crisis during the years 2007 but
dominoes go so i was
wondering about the identity of the port
he is
heading towards okay okay
my next question is the following
in recent months we have heard a lot
about the revelations of the
whistleblower antoine des aides  deltour and in
particular us in france and it has been
shown in particular that luxembourg has
allowed in the greatest secrecy to
multinationals like mcdonald's or
like pepsi to repatriate all their
profits made in the countries of europe
and to pay in the end only as %  of imp  ôts
me when I prepared this interview
I was surprised because my husband has a
small business and pays him 33
% taxes and suddenly the difference between
the two seemed enormous to me but
fortunately you declared that your
commission went  to do what is necessary
for this social injustice to
become a priority and suddenly I
was relieved but the question that
I asked myself next was and it
is perhaps a very naive question
is what in the end you really are
the  better placed to be able to put an end to
this social injustice because alas
it's nothing personal and it's
not an attack at all but I was wondering
confident that they never have life
really not but the question that  I
was asking myself confided in someone who
was finance minister for 18 years
of the largest tax haven in europe
the mission of fighting tax
evasion is what it would not
ultimately be a little bit like appointed
head of  police  a bank robber
yes finally it is often said that the
robbers the poachers
without constituted in our
police services leymergie léman but let's forget
that you relate to the country which is
mine
good I am no longer responsible a
superficial look which translates
condescension quite well  french
when she looks it's when the
french look at others in europe
each country
the tax haven of its neighbor is
what you are sure and certain that what
was called the text therefore underlines
the arrangements between
tax administrations and companies n  I haven't had a class
in France I'm sure of nothing
finally that's why I am and
you missed it very great pleasure
finally I tell you in a present
present that I know you will
discover will not please you
I agree but regardless of that
I was and I remain convinced that in
Europe we need a minimum
how to say
normality companies must pay  taxes
or where they make their profits
is what the
heart committee that I chair is about and we take it
very seriously as proven by the
decision on a little in verlan
and other decisions regardless of
country  of flags and people will
intervene during the weeks
of
next agreement but seven months I have never
taken a decision on the imposition of the
dial of a company in the grand duchy of
luxembourg it is the fed of dallas
saved  tax, which does not prevent us from
having discussions with the major
foreign investors who wanted to
establish themselves in Luxembourg, all the
first, especially finance, the care of
the major leaders of major international groups,
but there was never  how to say
an influence on the modalities the
details of the particular taxation
of an individual company I
would like all those who have helped
Prime Minister and Minister of
Finance in their country to be able to say the
same  okay thank you very much for his
explanations so
I see a little more clearly
and I do what you invited me
to react and we can of course look
with great pleasure at
my next question it is a question
that concerns me  was asked a lot by my
community
you know me I have a youtube channel
where I talk a lot about ecology and it's
a question about how
lobbies influence European laws and
in the previous question to the
first question I'm going  explain to you
that I was talking about lobbies in fact
in the organic sector, but the internet has placed
great emphasis on life on
the influx of lobbies in all
other areas and it reminds me, for
example, that citizens who elect
deputies elect deputies who
cannot pass laws and I
am surprised it is that in Brussels there are
between 20,000 and 30,000 lobbyists and the
industry who employ them
spend millions of euros to
gain influence suddenly I  think for example of
the case of philip morris who employs 160
people full time and who
gives them an envelope of 1.5
million euros to organize dinners and
events and finally I think I find
that these efforts are not in vain because
that in the end it bears fruit
and while searching I
also approached the pharmaceutical industry and
I realized that through
the various lobbies your committee
met, for example between 2014 and
2015, up to twice a week,
lobbyists  and I tell myself that it
necessarily creates a working relationship that
is held and above all that is maintained
by millions and what I'm trying
to get at is that
I am the president of a small
association in France, a
humanitarian association and  of an association linked to
organic and I wonder, for example, how can we
imagine that associations of
citizens like me, for example, can
have the same budgets and can
have the same opposition?  rtunits than
businesses and that brings me to the
question I wanted to ask you, which is that
ultimately I find it hard to believe that
the European Union can be the guarantor
of the general interest of the people rather
than the interest  companies
insofar as I have the impression that they
walk hand in hand a little bit
and in what I wanted to ask
you do you think that the European Union
is ultimately the guarantor of men and therefore
of human beings or rather
companies what is your feeling on
this subject there in a general way we
cannot systematically oppose the
two netizens the consumers and
the big pharmaceutical groups or
other but there is some truth in your
question first of all the deputies
Europeans vote the laws voted law
you said do not vote right they
vote laws
2 I ensured as soon as I took
office, of which you are the beginning,
the mandate of the current commission
to establish a register of transparency
therefore all  lobbyists you said
there the commission received between 2014 and
2015 either twice a week I do
n't know who how come you
know this
but because we publish
contact us and I made sure that
every year end  the president of the
commission vice-president the commercial
of the general manager finally
both must indicate to the general public
which are the lobbies which they received
in their office or in a tavern the
lower rooms so that in bag which has
it is  to have influence on which
decision
I am not opposed in principle
to lobbying if lobbying is a
participation is taken decision which
represents the interests of large
companies or consumer organizations
we also receive
environmental commitments
it is by the European Commission  who
gives their budget to lobbyists his life
on the other hand we
financially support other
more virtuous circles of influence such
as high garo  nnais of consumers and
and others so for me the main thing is
that Europeans know who saw who on
block by block subject this is what we
are a report in my
imagination as a citizen and young
women so that means that  basically we
have lobbyists who have thousands
of euros to be able to do their
lobbying work and the response we bring to the
face and to tell them well if you want
you can register in a notebook
to declare that you are a lobbyist
no no no no no it's me I'm receiving
let's say a big banker I let it be
known and so those who are watching me
can check whether or not the point
of view, moreover, always known of
this great pomp in August of a  large
company was able to produce affects
as to the content of the decisions which are
those of the commission and the council
then of the European parliament then
I am for full transparency
moreover I am not
the favorite of these
circles  okay I'm telling you this to
reassure you you reassure me listen
I asked you all my questions
and as time is running out I'm going
to thank you for having answered for having
played the game thank you very much
I would have liked to think about it but  I
too would have liked to continue with
pleasure but will have to interrupt
production at all it's not the
others
and yes I have to leave the
floor to my colleague who is just as
excited about me at the idea of ​​you
meet
yeah ok thank you very much it's a card
thank you see you soon I hope it's your
first time with a youtube is this
your first interview yes good work
continues good I hope we want
very soon and well take it if
Mr. President, we had a
very interesting and very frank discussion there
with Laeticia and I would like to slip in
here a little question that we also
had with
hb tac about what juncker in your
state of the union speech
you were concerned about  glitch that this
younger generation might be
poorer than their parents and it's not
just a question of poverty it's
a question of quality of life
this question and lino
investments don't matter
if  people continue to have
low wages poor
working conditions and poor
contracts on how to ensure that
economic growth leads
to good quality jobs complicated
the issue is more complex than it
seems to me of course it is  rather within the
competence of the member states than of the
commission and I was a Minister of
Labor for many years so I am
fully aware of this
problem, which
is moreover the reason why,
under the mandate of our commission,
we have  launched a consultation on
social rights minimum rights
for workers then the
necessary flexibility in certain cases
but it's a last few years it has
really stuck  given
social relations at national and
European level
indeed this blind flexibility has
sometimes been introduced into his
working relations my father
worked in the steel industry
if they had been confronted with
such employment contracts renewed
every six months
so  if he had had no
job security no future prospects
for a large part of his life
i think i would not have been able to
take courses at university
so i am very sensitive to this problem
of jobs  precarious
companies companies demand more
security
many workers must have the
same rights these questions are here
will resonate in the
youtube community and now I will introduce you to
the cash
he is Polish he conducts
interviews he is also dense where he is
very popular in his little
apartment in warsaw announced the
heads and he also has talk
decks on loads of topics you know  ez
that he met lady gaga it's this game
no but it was no choice nice to meet you
welcome welcome yes new
environment a beautiful life
first of all a little promotion for
my channel is what you know my
tokyo no no  at all to our films
to this game it's certain things
because I asked questions when I
meet lobbyists I want to
know who to my interlocutor
so I see quite well what you are
doing
thank you when I publish a note
when I  posted the note on your
interview people had mixed reactions
and i like and would love to know
what were the worst reviews of
you and how you reacted
iphone you don't talk about the
situation can talk to them in
general so
what I am regularly told is
that I do not speak enough to the
citizen that I am here in my
ivory tower towards words and that I am
not in contact with people I do
not know if you co  nborn luxembourg
it's a small country i
was minister of labor for 17
years i was minister of finance and
prime ministers also 19 years and
in luxembourg
don't think when you cross the
street that people will change
sidewalks when  you pass now
they are going your child what to
talk to you tell you now they are a
problem
the same thing is happening here in brussels
well there are of course security measures
that must be taken
when I am on mac years old it is  the
same thing
I don't feel like I'm cut off
from the world of
reality people talk to me they describe
their reality to me and so that's
the most frequent criticism
if you had to admit a mistake
as a politician it would be
which
happens often to very often in
montcalm is often
then what we will mislead
when I make decisions
which afterwards turns out to be stupid not
sufficiently thought through  not
thorough enough and i want to hold it
since i've been in politics i have a
principle when i change my mind i
say it it explains why you
never change your mind of course i
change my mind and you do it  explain to your
friends well my friends it's the general
public let's talk about the european union
how young europeans
can influence it
bolt is one of the flora
speaking up speaking out efforts
being critical
i don't think so  that we can really
progress if everyone says you
're right we have to tell you where we
're wrong he we have
to listen he doesn't necessarily have to give in but
sometimes certain decisions have to be
made
so sometimes this trick to  say who
agrees to say yes to everything good
asks you what they say yes yes
absolutely you are absolutely right
yes yes but that does not correspond
respected his interlocutor if you
respect those to whom you speak even if
he believes you  itic
you have to answer frankly given
an honest answer
sometimes it's a bridge these are crude
but these are spontaneous reactions and
sometimes when I come back to my
office I say to myself there was
indeed something right
there was real c  this is how I
try to do my job
good game of course it's not
always the case from 8 am to 8 pm it's not
possible to spend my time
wondering if everything is fine you also have to
decide  you have to know how to decide
what can brussels do so that a
question is more accessible
I come back to dealing with it I know that
young people do not really like the reference
to the treaty but it is the world in
which I live the treaties so they
favor  national competences
when it comes to education
it is not really a European mission
why because we have
overcome that Member State I do not know how many
regions enormously language and our
moments of culture enormously
colored  different people
so it is not possible to impose
a single easter solution
clearly explained how well
organized education let's take the example
of spain I shouldn't take
the example of poland
there is  the basics that he went Catalan
is then kingdom of spain
but things vary enormously from one
region to another
so how can we imagine that in brussels
commissioner or even the president say
here are so many hours of lessons
for german  as much for philosophy as
much for sport it's impossible
so it's a national competence but
what the european union can do
against 7 organized things
when necessary and in a
cross-border way
the university cycle of young people I'm
thinking of the  erasmus program millions
of young people have been able to take part in this
erasmus program
one young person in three has been able to take part in this
system we will take part in a twinning
is very often when it comes to a
training course in an e  business
well it is possible to then obtain
a contract and then there a
collateral effect 3 million marriages have been
concluded between young people participating in
the erasmus program a side effect
so we would like to develop the
erasmus program more since it
is not a question  only from a university
so it's also about learning
proposed game that we still create
young european volunteers
also i wish he could
get out of the robin start discovering the
world
helping others in solidarity in
crisis situations
the tremor  of land for example so
by 2020 I would like two hundred
thousand young people to take part in this
solidarity program because young people are
generous
it may be less true for my
generation but I will bring the weight back
to young people in a few years
they are looking to the future
they are the ones who have to prepare their
future and we who have to organize
we have to be in contact with these games  nes
and therefore this corps of volunteers
is in my opinion a good way to
enable young Europeans to
assume responsibilities
I listened to your speech yesterday yes and
I, beloved ones,
you said that the European Union
was not in good shape  why rise of
teeth i say them because sometimes
we give more importance to
our division
what commonality they the areas
in which we act in
solidarity are not enough
i would prefer like the differences
between the east the west  the north the south
finally that European financing is
done on the basis of principles which are
at the origin of the European union, that is
to say that we must move forward together
in the same direction
the army nation a state country does not matter
can survive alone in a
globalized world we are a small
continent europe is the smallest
continent we don't always know
because we still think we are the
masters of the world c  this is not the
case, moreover, the world does not
need to put people in
charge and not to put who would
decide how to do things so
we are the smallest continent and
therefore we do not have to  to invest in
our threshold differences is on the contrary
to find a common approach to
see how to move forward over the
next decades next century
auction - it's true
let's talk about your privacy what are
the advantages of your function of your
privacy
for him so there is none it's
not that i don't want to talk about it
i can't talk about my private life
of course i'm going to preserve my personal life
it's a fantastic idea
i don't like it i don't like it  am not a movie star either
i don't hear the next an oscar
i've seen a few videos you would have a
good chance of getting it
no no that's not quite what
i think and talk about  hugs not
yet if you wish I  can
kiss you right away well we have
media coverage now it's
done as long as we have seen no but to
come back to my private life
it is of course managed
separately from my professional life
as president of  the commission and
if I allow others to cynically take
a look at my private life and this
sows confusion since we no
longer make the distinction between the public man
that Jean presents and the private person
that I am a priest  toc whitson president
audois what do you do are there
procedures to follow when you
meet other presidents here what
do you do to contact them in france
or on board so that happens to me
regularly of course he is
generally a contact  personal with my
colleagues within the
european union and outside there are
some I have known for decades
i do not speak with them as
prime minister no that is not
how i see it  things I
establish personal relationships there
are sometimes conflicts it's true but
I have frank contacts I speak
as a human being to another
human being quite simply
that's the way it should be done
politics you may be able to get
in touch with barack obama more easily
and meet him when he is no longer
president you want me to
organize an appointment for you oh yes yes
gladly it will certainly be
interesting to organize an interview
I believe that  they would not appreciate that
I send you his phone number
thank you very much for this interview but
let it be
because one more word poland send a
message to all those who follow us in
poland it is very often said that my
heart is against  poland
not at all i say them to the
european parliament yesterday i dedicate poland is a
great country poland is a great nation
and i would like relations as
normal and frank as possible between
my ins  titution
the commission and poland that I love
very much thank you very much have experienced this yes
thank you I would like to thank its creators
laetitia yona its looks h
mr president
a shared pleasure
a big thank you mr president
only expert opinion
it is a  experience that we all
appreciated that we will recreate on
euronews and youtube
if you have on the site you re
news you will find other
articles on our subject in the meantime a
big thank you costs a proposal if
you allow for nothing to organize this
type of discussion  twice a year
with others of course not dragunov
you will be present you of course
but I would like to repeat this
experience
yes we will have to do
some girl scenes so
local cheese were going to tell me
that joker don't know bravo thank you thank you
very much
you stay there for a few more moments
thank you very much